in Europa hat der UK eine Krieg alles
verändert aber wie ist das zum Beispiel
in USA was ist in den USA vom
ukrainekrieg zu spüren ich habe ein Gast
bei mir den ich sehr herzlich begrüße
Ingo zamperoni Mister Tagesthemen vielen
Dank sie sind gerade vor einigen Wochen
aus den USA gekommen sie haben jetzt zu
den mithörens zu den Zwischenwahlen
sagen wir mal so noch einmal den USA
gedreht wie ist die Stimmung da wie
guckt man auf diesen Krieg in der
Ukraine also der ist schon präsent
allein auch in den Medien in den
Schlagzeilen auch in den
Nachrichtenkanälen sieht man ihn schon
zumal auch die US-Regierung unter Joe
Biden sehr involviert ist die
Unterstützung der Ukraine
die fahren gerade dem Amerikaner von
Anfang an sehr sehr hoch aber so im
Alltag ist es dann doch auch schon sehr
weit weg ich vergleiche das immer wie
weit oder wie nah waren uns hier kriege
in Syrien oder im Jemen das nehmen wir
wahr das nehmen wir auf aber es hat uns
dann erstangiert als hier Flüchtlinge
und geflüchtete wir haben in den USA im
Alltag gerade wenn man so im Herzland
unterwegs war wo wir diesen Sommer waren
im in der Mitte des Landes wo die Küsten
auch noch sehr weit weg sind sage ich
mal gefühlt
da ist das jetzt nicht so dass da dass
die Leute so sehr bewegt was sie schon
merken ist wenn der Sprit plötzlich sehr
viel teurer ist als es für amerikanische
Verhältnisse üblich ist oder dass die
Inflation derzeit auch dort unheimlich
vielen Menschen das Leben schwer macht
das wird dann schon auch gespürt und
dass das ein gewisser Weise auch mit
diesem Krieg zusammenhängt das kommt da
schon an aber es ist nicht so
vergleichbar wie mit uns hier in
Deutschland wo wir nur ein Land entfernt
sind von der Ukraine sie haben ja nicht
nur Amerikanistik studiert und in den
USA studiert
sondern sie haben auch eine
amerikanische Frau genau mein
Lebensthema sozusagen das Thema quasi
und sie haben jetzt die zweite
Dokumentation gemacht wenn man bei Ihnen
die Dokumentation von damals sich
anschaut dann kann man sehr viel finden
was darauf hindeutet das könnte mit ihm
klappen und das war sogar in ihrer
eigenen Familie so ich würde gerne in
ganz kurzen Ausschnitt mal zeigen aus
der damaligen
Dokumentation weil da war eine sehr
schöne Situation mit ihrem
Schwiegervater den sie nicht verstehen
konnten in der Reaktion zu Trump
dieser Präsident ist auf so vielen
Ebenen anders als alle davor
meine Level
naja es gibt viele Leute die nicht mögen
viele Republikaner viele dienen gewählt
haben
aber ich wähle die Partei und deren
Politik
ich sollte seine Persönlichkeit
eigentlich nicht ignorieren aber ich tue
das
perfekt
ich mag seinen Charakter nicht ich mag
nicht was er sagt ich mag nicht wie er
Leute kritisiert aber ich mag was er tut
es war eine ganz authentische Reaktion
von vielen Amerikanern wenn man mit
Amerikanern gesprochen hat dann sagten
die immer ja den Kaffee finden wir
furchtbar so wie er schwanger
Schwiegervater auch aber es gibt
bestimmte Gründe warum ich den wähle wie
kann man sich so unterschiedlich
entscheiden ich glaube es liegt in
erster Linie auch daran dass es in USA
dieses entweder oder Wahlsystem nur gibt
es gibt nur eine Partei A und eine
Partei und wenn man irgendwo dazwischen
liegt oder zumindest eine Wahl
ausschließt für sich dann bleibt er mir
nur die Alternative und wenn diese
Partei dann ein Kandidaten wieder Donald
Trump aufstellt dann ja dann haben das
Millionen Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner
so gemacht dass sie sich wie man
Schwiegervater die Nase zuhalten und
dann trotzdem dafür wählen weil nicht
wählen für viele auch keine Alternative
ist und es gibt nicht so eine Art
Protestwahl die man dann machen kann
oder so ein ausweichsystem aber es ist
tatsächlich auch so dass es viele gibt
die dann sagen okay persönlich kann ich
mit dem nichts anfangen aber vieles was
da entstanden ist die großen
Steuerreform und auch die Wahl der drei
obersten Richter am Supreme Court und so
das sind alles Punkte die für mich
wichtig sind und dann kann ich das
Ausblenden was da sonst so passiert
wir sprechen ja nicht deswegen aber
Donald Trump weil wir die Vergangenheit
sprechen wollen sondern weil er
möglicherweise auch eine Zukunft hat was
haben Sie denn bei ihren Dreharbeiten
für Reaktion in der Bevölkerung gefunden
bei den Amerikanern hat er aus der
Stimmungslage in den USA eine Shows also
eine Chance glaube ich auf jeden Fall
ich glaube es ist noch ein Tick zu früh
zu sagen ja Trump präsent Trump wird er
immer noch genannt in auch in den USA
das macht man mit ehemaligen Präsidenten
bis ans Lebensende
er wird auf jeden Fall glaube ich ein
Faktor sein in der Partei in der
republikanischen weil er so viel Gewicht
in die Waagschale bringt und auch jetzt
bei den Vorwahlen inzwischen waren in
den mitturms haben wir gesehen dass wir
viele Kandidat unterstützt haben die
dann eben auch sich durchgesetzt haben
ob er tatsächlich dann noch der Kandidat
der Republikaner wird da sind schon
viele auch mein Schwiegervater den wir
dieses Jahr diesen Sommer auch wieder
getroffen haben ja der sagt auch nach
wie vor ich finde ihn nicht gut ich
würde ihn wenn er der Kandidat würde
auch wieder wählen aber der setzt zu mir
seine Hoffnung auf jüngeren der Partei
wie Ron the sentes von Florida wo andere
wiederum sagen meine Frau auch der ist
fast noch gefährlicher in
Anführungsstrichen als Trump weil der
dieselbe Politik fährt aber bekömmlicher
herkommt nicht so rüpelhaft polternd den
kann man noch viel akzeptieren in
gewisser Weise für viele Wählerinnen und
Wähler und das ist glaube ich so die
Sache so nicht ausgemacht also ich
glaube der Wagen sich noch viele nicht
aus der Deckung viele warten so ein
bisschen auch diese mit terms ab um zu
schauen wie fällt denn da das Ganze aus
und daran wird es abhängig gemacht ich
glaube meine Frau würde sagen Trump wird
auf jeden Fall antreten allein um
irgendwelchen juristischen Dingen aus
dem Weg gehen zu können denn sollte er
präsent werden hätte er erstmal wieder
Immunität also das ist so ein ein
Argument dafür ich glaube in erster
Linie gefällt ihm die Aufmerksamkeit
dieses Spiel mit der Frage kommt der
kommt ja nicht alle stehen so ein
bisschen gebannt wie die Kaninchen vor
der Schlange und damit spielt er
unheimlich gerne diese Aufmerksamkeit
das ist das was in erster Linie braucht
wenn sie die Situation und die Atmos
oder die sie jetzt auch erlebt haben
vergleichen mit der Zeit vor der Wahl
von Trump wie unterscheidet sie sich ich
glaube es ist eher hat sich sogar eher
verstärkt also Faktoren die dafür
gesorgt haben dass er gewählt wurde von
vielen die sich entweder abgehängt
fühlten oder gesagt haben unter die die
Wirtschaft ist so viel wichtiger da muss
mehr getan werden und jetzt mit
inflationsrekordwerten und auch mit dem
teuren Spritpreis und wo vieles eben
schwer haben über die Runden zu kommen
ist das ein Feld ein Umfeld in dem die
eine trump-botschaft natürlich sehr gut
reinpasst insofern die Stimmung glaube
ich auch diese Teilung in der
Gesellschaft diese Spaltung die hat sich
noch mehr zementiert habe ich das Gefühl
es ist noch mehr politischer egal was
man macht ob jetzt Co wird oder oder
Klimaschutz es ist immer gleich entweder
oder wir gucken eigentlich überrascht
über das was da passiert und auch über
diese Aufteilung obwohl wir ja ähnliche
Tendenzen auch in anderen Ländern haben
auch in Italien im übrigen massive
Tendenzen sagen wir mal zwischen zwei
Blöcken in der Bevölkerung müssen wir
später noch drüber reden wenn sie aber
noch mal auf die Familiensituation
zurückkommen war das ein handfester
Streit in der Familie oder hat man sich
sehr ruhig und argumentativ wie auf dem
Golfplatz ständig unterhalten darüber
also ich habe das Glück oder wir haben
das Glück in unserer Familie dass da der
Gesprächsfaden noch nicht gerissen ist
und das auch meine Frau sagt ist es mir
das wert über wie auch immer der jetzt
gerade im Weißen Haus sitzt mit meinem
Vater zu brechen und dann sagt sie sich
nein es ist nicht und dann sage ich okay
mein Vater wird immer so wahrscheinlich
bis ans Lebensende so jetzt denken auch
wenn er vielleicht früher anders gewählt
hat und und ich bin aber genauso auf
meiner Schiene wenn man so will und und
trotzdem finden wir dann weg und kommen
da zusammen aber es gibt viele Familien
in USA wo das nicht mehr der Fall ist wo
man sich ein zweites Szene an weil ihre
Frau damit ihrem Vater diskutiert und
zwar in der Küche
Trump hat mehr in 47 Monaten erreicht
als beiden in 47 Jahren hoffentlich wird
er nicht viel länger als 47 Monate im
Amt sein ich finde es gut was er gemacht
hat und deshalb wähle ich die Partei
nicht ihn
Trumps Partei geworden es ist nicht mehr
die Partei die du früher gewählt hast
die Demokraten sind auch nicht beides
Partei
die Rücken nach links haben aber nicht
so eine Schieflage wie die anderen und
sind nicht so Partei einer Kultfigur
geworden die Republikaner sind total auf
Trump fixiert die stehen nicht mehr für
das dass du immer geglaubt hast Trump
geht es nur um sein Ego und sein
Vermächtnis und wenn davon ein paar mehr
keine profitieren ein paar Amerikaner
ein paar die Arbeitslosigkeit ist
gesunken wie nie bei den Latinos den
schwarzen
weißen Frauen und das hat mit seiner
Politik zu tun
natürlich hat
die Steuern für viele gesenkt deshalb
können Sie jetzt mehr Leute beschäftigen
sie beschäftigen sich nachher mit dem
gemüseschäden um da ich noch eingreifen
zu müssen aber ich hatte die Rolle wer
das Beobachters und das ist tatsächlich
ein Streit der sehr häufig schnell
entbrennt zwischen den beiden und und
die werden sich auch wir haben diesen
Sommer auch wieder so ähnliche Situation
kreiert diesmal geht sich um Salat
schälen sondern wir haben fürs Barbecue
haben wir Maiskolben geschält ja aber es
ist halt so dass glaube ich dieses
verfestigte dieser Blöcke das schwer
macht er überhaupt die andere Seite zu
sehen und und das ist natürlich von der
Demokratie nicht und das ist nicht
typisch amerikanisch nur das gibt es wie
Sie sagten auch in vielen anderen
Ländern auch in Europa wir sind das auch
hier bei uns in Deutschland teilweise
aber da ist es natürlich gleich so mit
den mit den entsprechenden Folgen aber
warum wir auf die USA immer schauen ist
es ist der wichtigste größte
Bündnispartner und wir erleben das jetzt
gerade beim Krieg in der Ukraine sehr
deutlich
und dieses transatlantische Verhältnis
ist ja auch man muss es sagen deutlich
enger geworden seit Beginn dieses UK
eine Krieges man hat vorher so ein
bisschen auch im Rahmen der NATO gesagt
naja sagte es ist eigentlich Hirntod da
passiert nicht mehr so viel das ist viel
enger geworden trotzdem gucken wir auch
deswegen doch hin weil da Dinge
passieren wir am 6 Januar der Sturm aufs
Kapitol
die wir auch als sie sind genauso als
Journalist an solchen Ereignissen
interessiert und fragen sich wie kann so
etwas passieren in der Bevölkerung gar
nicht mal jetzt eine Reaktion erfolgt
jetzt ist Trump durch jetzt verstehen
wir gar nicht mehr was da passiert so im
Gegenteil ja im Gegenteil auch bei den
Politikern die das hautnah miterlebt
haben die teilweise mehr Leben
gefürchtet haben im Kongress an dem an
dem auf dem Capitol an dem Abend die
haben dann Wochen später nur bereits
schon gesagt also schlimm war das ja gar
nicht auf der republikanischen Seite und
es hat bis auf wenige Ausnahmen ist auch
bei den Untersuchungsausschüssen haben
wir nur zwei Republikaner mitgemacht die
dafür jetzt auch abgestraft wurden von
der Partei
allen voran Liss
warreni meine ich die die jetzt eben
nicht mehr ihren Posten haben wird weil
sie abgewählt wurde und insofern ist das
schon erstaunlich dass sich das so
trennen lässt weil viele eben sagen das
ist eine Hexenjagd das ist das einzige
worauf die Demokraten jetzt ihre
Hoffnung setzen für die mütterns und ich
glaube was viele verschreckt hat aber
ist es hat gezeigt dass die Frage wird
es in den USA ein Bürgerkrieg geben oder
irgend sowas und ich glaube das nicht
aber die Gefahr dass es eben Menschen
gibt die bei der nächsten Wahl die nicht
so im Sinne der Republikaner vielleicht
ausgehen sollte das dann Menschen sagen
okay jetzt müssen wir selber das in die
Hand nehmen ist unsere patriotische
Pflicht notfalls auch mit Waffengewalt
irgendwas durchzudrücken das ist dann
soeben zu Gewaltausbrüchen kommen kann
die Gefahr sich durchaus und das ist das
besorgniserrecken wir sehen ja ganz
viele Dinge die in Europa auch in
Deutschland stattfinden in sehr
eklatanten dramatischen Formen in den
USA sie haben gerade die Waffen
angesprochen sie schön in einem ihrer
Bücher eine Situation als sie aus dem
Fenster gucken und Polizeiwagen durch
die Straßen fahren ein riesen Stau
entsteht und in dieser Pizzeria
jemand mit Waffen eindringt und sagt ich
befreie diese von Pädophilen
festgehaltenen Kinder man fragt sich ja
kann so etwas in Europa passieren die
Tendenzen des Populismus und der
Radikalität sind sicherlich da ist der
Amerika Vorreiter ist es immer sehr viel
radikaler in USA bei diesen Dingen die
USA sind in vielen Bereichen im Land der
Extreme und das trifft in diesem Fall
eben auch zu ich glaube es wird in einem
Land von 360 Millionen Menschen eben
auch welche geben die dann sich berufen
fühlen
da die Sachen die eigene Hand zu nehmen
und das eben auch mit Waffengewalt dann
und das ist dann natürlich eine Ausnahme
auch gewesen aber es zeigt dass das
nicht nur das Verschwörungstheorien
einfach nur so an spinnerte Idee sind
sondern tatsächlich das Auswirkungen
haben kann da ist zum Glück niemand zu
Schaden gekommen an dem Tag aber das
kann durchaus wir haben es neulich
wieder erlebt dass jemand dann zum FBI
Büro nach diesem nach dieser
Untersuchung des Trump schon Anwesenden
Florida durch das FBI dann ist jemand
hingegangen mit einer Knarre in der Hand
und wollte da quasi ich weiß noch nicht
mal richtig was er da wollte auf jeden
Fall das Ergebnis war dass die Beamten
ihn erschossen haben in weil sie sich
selbst verteidigt haben und das ist das
ist immer wieder eine Gefahr noch einem
Land wo es eine Menge Veteranen noch
gibt die traumatisiert aus kriegen
zurückgekommen sind aus dem Irak aus
Afghanistan und mittlerweile ist eine
Menge Fokus auch drauf aber doch sehr
viele eben nicht die psychische Hilfe
auch bekommen und und dann eben auch
alleine gelassen werden
ganz viele Punkte ich habe jetzt gerade
gesagt sind extremer sie haben das ja
gerade bestätigt extreme auch der Umgang
mit
Migranten der Umgang im Zusammenhang mit
Rassismus wie kommt das
die USA sind ja wenn man so will ein
gigantisches Feldexperiment seit mehr
als 200 Jahren kommen Menschen aus aller
Welt in dieses Land und es ist immer so
die letzte Einwanderungsgruppe die
gerade noch quasi jetzt gekommen ist es
dann die erste die sagt jetzt ist das
Boot aber voll so ungefähr habe ich den
Eindruck und
es ist ein Land das von dieser Dynamik
aber auch lebt und profitiert und die
erneuerungskräfte in amerikanischen
Gesellschaft sind genau basierend auf
dieser
Einwanderung und trotzdem ist es
natürlich so dass es Veränderung mit
sich bringt die USA werden noch
multikultureller noch
vielschichtiger und natürlich ist diese
eine Gewissheit die viele weiß auch
hatten dass wir zwar aus aller Herren
Länder Zuwanderung bekommen aber die
eine dominante Ethnie sind eben die
weißen und das verändert sich gerade und
da ist eine Menge in Bewegung und im
Fluss und das sind auch verlusteängste
dabei denke ich und ich glaube da ist
eine Menge
Abwehrhaltung gegenüber einer
unkontrollierten Einwanderung ich glaube
auch mein Schwiegervater zum Beispiel
dem diese Lage an der Grenze
in Dorn im Auge ist der sagt auch
Einwanderung ist gut wir brauchen einen
Wanderung aber es soll kontrolliert sein
und legal und nicht jeder hier der
nachts über den Rio Grande wartet oder
durch wartet und dann hier
versickern buchstäblich in den ganzen
Systemen und das ist das was vielen
Schreck liegt
wir müssen mal auf die Rolle der Medien
kommen die haben sie auch beschrieben da
gibt es dann so Sätze wie
Trump ist ja grauenvoll aber gut fürs
CBS also eine ganz pragmatische Haltung
der der Fernsehanstalten in USA die
sagen wir holen uns unglaubliche Quoten
damit
Medium Fernsehen spielt eine ganz ganz
entscheidende Rolle bei Trump ist es
vielleicht die entscheidende Rolle
überhaupt gewesen sie haben das
beschrieben wie weit ist das denn heute
in den USA so naja auf Twitter ist er ja
mundtot gemacht worden da reicht das ein
Publikum nicht mehr und hat auch nicht
mehr glaube ich diese Wirkung auf seinen
eigenen Kanälen jetzt gleichwohl ist das
natürlich ein großes Thema wobei ich
dann immer sage was war Hände was war
ein also natürlich ist die Faszination
das haben wir auch in Deutschland in den
Medien wenn Trump auf dem Titel von von
Zeitung war oder auch Sendung das ist
ein Interesse das ist ja quasi die
Ausnahme von der Norm gewesen und nach
wie vor und wir reden immer noch auch
darüber aber gleichzeitig ist ja nicht
so das Medien das reindrücken soll Leute
wir wollen euch hier Trump vorführen
konsumiert das bitte sondern da das
bedingt sich beides gegenseitig aber es
ist schon so dass glaube ich die Medien
eine
brandbeschleunigende Funktion leider
haben dabei und will uns ja gar nicht
ausnehmen aber ich glaube in den USA wo
man auch sehr viele Medien die sehr
Agenda getrieben sind die eine gewisse
Ausrichtung auch haben in beide
Richtungen nicht nur in die konservative
auch in die andere progressive das ist
nicht dienlich ist weil es eben nicht
versucht Seiten zu zeigen die es auch
auf der anderen Seite der Medaille gibt
sondern eben quasi eine Seite bestärkt
weil es sich verkauft weil es gut
ankommt bei der jeweiligen Basis und das
ist glaube ich nicht wirklich Diskurs
fördernd und letztlich auch nicht
Demokratie fördern wir haben jetzt sehr
viel über Donald Trump gesprochen weil
er ja auch als Synonym oder passepototo
für diese sagen wir mal Radikalität in
der Populismus steht Rassismus steht und
so weiter jetzt hat sich ja die beiden
etwas verändert spürt man das im Land ja
und nein also meine Familie zum Beispiel
die sagen immerhin ist jetzt mit beiden
jemand der ein bisschen staatsmanager
auftritt und dem man wieder vorzeigen
kann so ungefähr im Amt und gleichzeitig
ist bei vielen doch so die Enttäuschung
gewesen die waren von Anfang an nicht so
begeistert er war halt nicht Trump das
war das große Argument für Joe Biden ich
glaube insgesamt hatte sich schon sehr
bemüht in gewisser Weise aber ist jetzt
nicht so dass alle sagen hey klasse und
hoffentlich bleibt ihr noch eine weitere
Amtszeit im amtlich glaube man hat ja
gehofft dass keinerley Harris sozusagen
ihm nachfolgt aber das scheint nicht der
Fall zu sein wen gibt es denn da da ist
noch nicht so richtig klar wer das sein
könnte ich glaube nicht dass es eine
zweite Amtszeit beiden geben wird wir
haben in einem Buch noch mal geschrieben
dass diese
Trennung diese klare Trennung die wir
als Journalisten gelernt haben in
unseren Anfängen von Meinungen und
Nachricht sich immer mehr auflöst das
ist überall so das ist ein Zeichen auch
dieses Populismus ja und es ist auch
Social Media geschuldet weil Social
Media das natürlich immer alles was
aufregt was Traffic generiert läuft dann
auch gut und dadurch ist es auch eher
nicht Diskurs fördern sondern eher
spaltend und ich glaube da ist auch
etwas was an sozialen Netzwerken so toll
sie für viele sind und so wichtig auch
wo echt so ein Baufehler in gewisser
Weise ist aber erleben wir deinen USA
etwas was bei uns sich dann auch noch
fortschreiben wird und und vielleicht
möglicherweise auch noch stärker
ausprägen wird es sind die USA da ein
bisschen weiter fast schon ich glaube
durchaus also wir sind bei weitem nicht
davor gefeit wir sind vielleicht ein
bisschen wenn man sieht in Europa haben
wir ja auch in Frankreich in Italien
auch in Großbritannien gewisse Form von
Populismus und auch hier glaube ich ist
das nicht das ist nicht etwas was bei
uns nicht möglich wäre ich glaube wir
sind insgesamt hat ein bisschen die
Deutschen sind ein bisschen
zurückhaltender oder vielleicht auch
temperierter in vielem wir haben nicht
so diese Ausschläge wir haben ich sag
nur 16 Jahre eine Kanzlerin gehabt und
davon drei Mal eine große Koalition ja
also wo eben viel in der Mitte basiert
ist und wir haben weniger an den Rändern
an dahin trifft es in den USA immer mehr
auch in den Parteien also bei den
Demokraten mehr so in die progressive
Richtung und bei den Republikanern eben
eher in diese Trump Richtung aber Ingo
zauberoni muss ich natürlich Fragen in
Frankreich haben wir eine ähnliche
Entwicklung nach links und nach rechts
radikal in Italien auch und wenn man
gehört hat wie die Wähler darauf
reagieren etwa bei der französischen
Wahl aber jetzt auch bei der Wahl in
Italien dann haben die immer gesagt wir
probieren das einfach mal aus kann man
nicht demokratische Parteien oder
Kandidatinnen oder Kandidaten
ausprobieren wie kommt es zu dieser
Entwicklung vielleicht schon vorsichtig
sein muss dass es ja doch demokratisch
gewählte
Kandidatinnen und Kandidaten sind in
gewisser Weise ja aber möglicherweise
Teile Demokratie abschaffen wollen die
Teile davon abschaffen wollen das ist
richtig aber man würde ich glaube schon
dass man nicht sagen kann okay die kann
man ja nicht wählen sondern da sind
viele die gesagt haben bis was bislang
die Politik uns vorgelegt hat hat uns
nicht erreicht oder nicht befriedigende
Antworten bereitet dann schauen wir mal
was haben wir dazu verlieren und ich
glaube so ein bisschen von der Haltung
war eben bei den Trump bei der
trump-wahl 2016 auch zu spüren oder bei
den vielen die ihnen wiedergewählt haben
und
deswegen sage ich jetzt nicht wird schon
alles gut also ich glaube schon dass es
da wenn rechtsextreme in machtvolle
Position gewählt werden dann ist das
natürlich besorgniserregend aber das ist
so ein bisschen das Votum der
Wienerinnen und Wähler gerade in Italien
eben auch gewesen zu sagen okay bislang
haben wir von den drei Parteien die
jetzt dieses Bündnis schmieden zwei ja
auch regiert also vorzeitalia und leger
waren ja auch an der Macht und dann
schauen wir mal wie das jetzt damit
funktioniert aber immer ein Strich
runter zu ziehen und zu sagen also in
den letzten zwei oder vier Jahren massiv
das so und so und das ist nicht gut
gelaufen bedeutet ja die Politik hat
bestimmte Dinge die ich im Griff
bekommen wie hätte sie denn jetzt einen
Ukraine Krieg oder eine Energiekrise in
den Griff bekommen können kann man die
überhaupt verantwortlich machen für eine
solche Situation da sagen ja die
Populisten macht die pipelands wieder
auf redet mit Putin der soll Gas liefern
dann ist das Problem gelöst das ist ja
Rainer Populismus ja ich glaube das ist
eine Herausforderung sie hat glaube ich
keiner der gerade in
Regierungsverantwortung ist kommen sehen
und sich gewünscht weil das natürlich
eine absolute Ausnahmesituation ist und
ich glaube das ist immer so ein Versuch
dahinter her zu kommen und sich auf den
Sattel endlich setzen zu können um das
Ganze ein bisschen zu stabilisieren
in Italien ist es tatsächlich so dass da
auch sehr viel Machtpolitik einfach auch
im Spiel ist und da gewisse
Unzufriedenheiten auch ausgenutzt worden
um dann zu sagen okay jetzt eigentlich
wäre die Regierung Draghi sehr mäßigen
Regierung und dann hat man gesagt okay
jetzt nutzen wir das aber aus und und es
hat geklappt aus Sicht der des
rechtsbündnis da sozusagen
ich glaube es ist total schwierig da
jetzt die befriedigenden Antworten
sofort zu finden aber zu sagen ja gut
dann dann versuchen wir es erst gar
nicht ist ja auch keine Lösung also ich
glaube deswegen will ich jetzt gerade
nochmal auf die Amerikaner weil sie eben
auch noch mal beschrieben haben das ist
eine andere Mentalität
nicht nur positiv sondern auch im
Negativen aber es ist auch eine
zupackende Mentalität eine die nicht so
schnell klagt sondern sagt wir müssen
das wieder aufbauen wir hatten gerade
diesen unglaublich furchtbaren Hurricane
in Florida wenn wir die Bilder gesehen
haben konnte man sich gar nicht mehr
vorstellen dass man das wieder aufbauen
können aber die Amerikaner sind so die
bauen das jetzt auch wieder auf
wir in Europa sind da ein bisschen
anders sie haben ja nun beide
Mentalitäten kennengelernt sind wir in
der Lage diese Krise jetzt auch ähnlich
wie die Amerikaner anzugehen pragmatisch
zu sagen ja dann müssen wir eben ein
bisschen weniger Temperatur haben und
ein bisschen konsequenter mit Sparen
umgehen und dann kriegen wir das hin das
wäre der amerikanische Reaktion in
gewisser Weise schon ja also dieses
nicht darauf hoffen und bauen dass
irgendeine Obrigkeit irgendeine
staatliche Einrichtung sich schon drum
kümmert sondern selber anzupacken und zu
sagen okay Mund abwischen und wieder
aufstehen dass eine sehr amerikanische
Haltung in vielem und hat dem Land auch
immer wieder geholfen ich glaube das ist
die hier auch gibt in vielerlei Hinsicht
dass wir da auch schon ich glaube wir
jetzt noch nicht kapiert hat in welcher
Situation wir uns insgesamt gerade
befinden zwischen Pandemie noch und eben
dem Krieg in Ukraine vor dem ganzen nach
der Hintergrund der das Klimawandels und
der Klimakrise was ja noch überhaupt
nicht weggegangen ist sondern am Top ist
das
dass da eben schon viele auch diese
Ernsthaftigkeit erkannt haben und sagen
okay wir müssen da jetzt auch damit
anpacken und nicht nach dem Motto naja
lass die anderen mal machen unser Leben
hier soll sich nicht ändern ich glaube
dass das schon viele kapiert haben das
ändert der Umzug aus den USA nach
Deutschland erfolgt mit drei Kindern und
diese drei Kinder die haben auch viel
von Amerika mitbekommen zumindest
schildern Sie das in ihren Büchern auch
die die älteste glaube ich hat den
Spruch America first beziehungsweise
dann geschrieben
Amerika think again also sie soll die 20
mal klar werden was da überhaupt
passiert in den USA wie stark haben die
sich jetzt an einer europäische oder
deutsche Mentalität wieder gewöhnt oder
gibt es da so ein ach ich glaube es gibt
immer so habe ich das auch selber als
ich aufgewachsen bin immer wieder
erfahren diese dieses zu Hause sein in
zwei Mentalität und Kulturen und das
nicht als Bürde oder Herausforderung zu
sehen sondern als Restaurants als Zusatz
also ich habe das immer empfunden als
Bereicherung und so empfinden die das
glaube ich auch und es ist relativ
einfach für sie auch zu switchen und
zwischen den Kulturen hin und her zu
springen und auch die Gemeinsamkeiten zu
sehen und uns immer davon zu profitieren
auch wir haben ja noch eine sehr enge
Beziehung zu den USA wegen der
Schwiegereltern und wechseln ja immer
noch hin und her haben wir eine Chance
eine Perspektive aus dieser tiefen Krise
der
Politiker der sich jetzt hinstellt und
sagt dass die schwierigste Situation die
wir seit 1945 haben ist ja auch der
Kanzler zur Zeit wir müssen da ja eine
Zeitenwende eigentlich in den Fokus
nehmen haben wir eine Chance das mit
unserer Mentalität hinzubekommen
ich glaube schon ich grundsätzlich bin
ich ja der Optimist und das will ich
auch den deutschen nicht mal zugute
halten und diese Glas eher halb
vollsicht Weise die haben hier viel und
deswegen habe ich in der Pandemie auch
angefangen meine Sendung bei den
Tagesthemen bleiben sie zuversichtlich
zu beenden einfach weil ich denke wir
haben wirklich so viel auch worauf wir
nicht nur stolz sein können sondern was
wir auch schaffen trotz allem und und
wir sehr vieles ist Jammern auf dem
relativ hohen Niveau auch und da nicht
immer gleich die Flinte ins Korn zu
werfen sozusagen okay jetzt sind die
Zeit Nummer anders vielleicht haben wir
auch lange zu lange in der gewissen
Blase der Glückseligkeit gelebt
unberührt von vielem was der Rest der
Welt schon immer oder nach wie vor
mitbekommen hat und jetzt erreicht es
halt eben auch uns das könnte man fast
schon sagen endlich mal in gewisser
Weise dass wir da aufwachen und und die
Welt nicht so in Watte gepackt auch
sehen und ich glaube das das kommt schon
bei vielen an das macht natürlich Angst
und das ist auch
kein kein Normalzustand strebenswert
wäre natürlich aber ein gewisser Weise
ist ja vielleicht realitätsnah als was
wir davor hatten wir haben ja davon
gesprochen zu Beginn dass dieses
Verhältnis zwischen USA und Europa und
auch zu Deutschland sehr viel enger
geworden ist durch den Ukraine Krieg
aber letztendlich ist ja die
Fokussierung der USA in Richtung Asien
das muss man eindeutig sehen wie stark
haben sie das empfunden das ist ja jetzt
eine sehr schwierige Situation auch für
die USA auch für die Politik in den USA
die so quasi beide Spielfelder bedienen
muss ich glaube das war auch gar nicht
auf dem Zettel von von niemanden
wahrscheinlich vom Präsident beiden der
eben auch die Ausrichtung dieser pirator
der unter präsent Obama ja schon
begonnen hatte weiter fortzuführen weil
für die USA China als der große
Gegenspieler nicht nur am Horizont ist
sondern auch schon sehr präsent in
vielerlei Hinsicht und darauf wollte man
sich glaube ich konzentrieren jetzt hat
dieser Krieg in der Ukraine die USA
wieder mehr zum transatlantischen
Verhältnis zu Europa hingezogen und hat
der nat dadurch noch mal ein Schub
gegeben auch Sinn vielleicht wieder
gegeben aber diese dieser Ausrichtung
nach nach dem pazifischen Raum die
bleibt nach wie vor stark ist einfach
noch nicht vergessen dass das
europäischer Sicht das das eben das sind
zwei Küstenland ist und die eben ein
Pazifik Anrainer mit sehr vielen
Interessen wirtschaftlichen
geostrategischen in dieser Region da
werden sie sich versuchen nach wie vor
zu zeigen zu gerade auch taiwan ist
jetzt natürlich ein Thema für viele was
passiert deswegen waren jetzt auch diese
ganzen Delegationen die Nancy Palace die
Sprecherin des Hauses war zu Besuch da
und und kritisiert wurde war so
kritisiert wurde als Öl ist Feuer gießen
aber in gewisser Weise ist das auch die
Haltung nee wir hatten hier Präsenz dass
unsere Verbündeten die werden wir
versuchen nach allen möglichen zu
schützen und zu unterstützen das wird
nicht weggehen aber gleichzeitig ist es
auch nicht so dass es sich jetzt alles
abwendet natürlich ist der die meiste
Einwanderung kommt aus Südamerika und
Mittelamerika einerseits aber aus dem
asiatischen Raum weniger aus dem
europäischen und das verändert auch die
amerikanische Gesellschaft und Blick auf
die Welt und auf die was passiert in
Kalifornien zum Beispiel ist natürlich
der asiatische Raum sehr viel näher als
das was bei uns hier in Deutschland
passiert und ich glaube wir müssen in
Deutschland nicht mal so wir sind doch
hier auf Augenhöhe wir sind doch hier so
der manchmal wie so das Gefühl so wir
wollen der große Bruder bzw wir sind der
kleine Bruder der auf Augenhöhe mit dem
großen sein will und sind dann immer
beleidigt wenn es nicht so klappt und
eine andere Richtung guckt aber es
gehört auch dazu hat ja viel mit
Motivation zu tun ihr schlussspruch bei
den Tagesthemen den nehmen wir jetzt mal
vielleicht ein bisschen anders auf es
gibt ja auch den Grundsatz Spruch lief
im laughing also man sollte mit
Lockerheit aufhören sie tun das in den
Tagesthemen diese Zuversicht ist
vielleicht ja auch eine Zuversicht die
daraus kommt dass wir wirklich auch noch
mal merken USA und Europa stehen da in
dieser Krise zusammen und das könnte ja
tatsächlich auch eine Lösung mit
herbeiführen ich glaube es geht nur
gemeinsam es gibt nur gemeinsame
Lösungen dafür sowohl Energiekrise als
auch auf jeden Fall die Klimakrise da
müssen wir aber auch die Russen und die
Chinesen und auch alle mit an Bord
kriegen also das ist jetzt nicht nur ein
transatlantisches Problem dass man da
gemeinsam anfasst ich glaube tatsächlich
das ist eine Chance und wir haben auch
gar keine große Wahl oder eine andere
Wahl als diesen Multilateralismus und
das ist ja das was wir gehofft hatten
unter beiden dass das wiederkommt und so
ist es ja auch wiedergekommen dass das
eben that's the way sozusagen ja und und
ich glaube dass da eine Menge Chancen
und Perspektiven darin auch sind bei
allen Hindernissen und und allen
Beschwerden die wir noch vor uns haben
bin mal gespannt auf die Dokumentation
ganz herzlichen Dank Ingo Zappa auch
nicht dass sie bei uns waren vielen
herzlichen Dank für die Einladung
[Musik]